Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Forbidden from sleeping with men, the Egozi, the regiment of immensely fierce female warriors who fought for the kingdom of Dahomey, were recruited when young and forced to undergo the kind of military training that would turn most of us into conscientious objectors. One British traveller described how the women were forced to scramble across dense thickets of acacia thorns without anything to protect their feet from bleeding. Other tests were designed to desensitise them to the horrors of combat. Every year, new recruits of both sexes were required to mount a platform 16 feet high,
感谢收听《历史的其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。埃戈齐（Egozi）是一支由极其凶猛的女性战士组成的军团，她们曾为达荷美王国战斗，并被禁止与男性发生性关系。她们在年轻时就被招募，并被迫接受那种会让我们大多数人都变成坚定的兵役反对派的军事训练。一位英国旅行者曾描述这些女性如何被迫穿过茂密的金合欢刺丛，双脚没有任何保护，鲜血直流。其他测试则旨在让她们对战争的恐怖感到麻木。每年，不论男女的新兵都被要求登上一个16英尺高的平台，
pick up baskets containing bound and gagged prisoners of war, and hurl them over the parapet to a baying mob below. And in perhaps the most horribly memorable detail, a French officer called Jean Bayol, watched as a teenage recruit called Naniska, who had not yet killed anyone, was brought before a captured young man whose hands were bound. According to Bayol, she swung her sword three times with both hands, then calmly cut the last flesh that attached the head to the trunk. She then squeezed the blood off her weapon and swallowed it. Nice.
拿起装有被捆绑且堵住嘴的战俘的竹篮，然后将他们从胸墙上扔到下方狂热的暴民中。或许其中最可怕、最令人难忘的细节是，一位名叫让·巴约尔（Jean Bayol）的法国军官看到，一个名叫娜尼丝卡（Naniska）的十几岁新兵——她此前还没有杀过人——被带到一个双手被绑的年轻男子面前。据巴约尔描述，她双手挥剑三次，然后平静地切断了连接头部和躯干的最后一块皮肉。接着，她擦掉武器上的血并将其咽了下去。真是不错。
Now that was top historian of Africa, Dominic Sandbrook. Oh my word. Writing in Unheard, U-N-H-E-R-D. And Dominic, you were prompted to write that article. Yeah, based on my own close research age yes well that's very evident but that was inspired by the woman king a film that came out um last september yes the viola davis john bieger film which is about the formidable amazon warriors of dahomey at least that's how they were presented, wasn't it? Then there was a huge storm, if you remember, because Dahomey
刚才那是非洲顶级历史学家多米尼克·桑德布鲁克（Dominic Sandbrook）。天哪。他在《Unheard》杂志上撰文，即U-N-H-E-R-D。多米尼克，你是什么促使你写那篇文章的？是的，基于我自己的深入研究。是的，这很明显。但这灵感来自于去年九月上映的电影《女王》（The Woman King），对吧？也就是维奥拉·戴维斯（Viola Davis）和约翰·博耶加（John Boyega）主演的那部电影，讲的是达荷美强大无比的亚马逊女战士。至少电影里是这么展现她们的，对吧？然后，如果你还记得的话，引发了一场巨大的风暴，因为达荷美
was a kingdom, an empire based partly on slavery. So there was a huge storm about whether or not these characters should be portrayed as anti-slavery freedom fighters, as they were in the film, or whether this was traducing the historical record. And lots of people on social media got really agitated and tore lumps out of each other about it. And I thought, I'm going to wade in. I thought this was on social media got really agitated and tore lumps out of each other about it and i thought i'm gonna wade in i thought this is a great opportunity to write about my favorite subjects
是一个王国，一个部分建立在奴隶制基础上的帝国。因此，关于这些角色究竟应该像电影中那样被描绘成反奴隶制的自由斗士，还是这歪曲了历史记录，引发了一场轩然大波。社交媒体上的许多人都极其激动，并为此吵得不可开交。而我想，我要介入其中。我觉得这真是个在社交媒体上……呃，对此感到极其激动并吵得不可开交，而我想，我要介入其中，我觉得这是一个极好的机会，可以写我最喜欢的主题
which are blood and guts i did and so you took it yeah okay and so this idea that you know that there were regiments of of what european observers at the time called amazons it's obviously i mean it's a kind of incredible detail it seems barely plausible plausible. But then I met Luke Pepperer, who is an anthropologist, historian, a broadcaster. And Luke, you're busy writing a book, Motherland, 500,000 Years of African History, Cultures and Identity, which I think will be coming out in 2025. And you said that this theme of Amazons in Africa, that I wasn't just kind of projecting Eurocentric fantasies. Please reassure me that I wasn't, that this is something that is actually a feature of
那就是血腥暴力。我确实写了，所以你接招了，是啊，好吧。所以这种观点，你知道的，当时欧洲观察家称之为亚马逊的军团，这显然，我的意思是，这是一种令人难以置信的细节，似乎几乎难以置信。但后来我遇到了卢克·佩佩尔（Luke Pepperer），他是一位人类学家、历史学家和广播员。卢克，你正在忙着写一本书《祖国：非洲历史、文化与身份的50万年》（Motherland, 500,000 Years of African History, Cultures and Identity），我想这本书将会在2025年出版。你说过，非洲的亚马逊女战士这个主题，并不只是我某种程度上投射出的欧洲中心主义幻想。请向我保证我没有这样做，这实际上是
various places in Africa. Yeah, no, definitely. I mean, female fighting forces, soldiers, military commanders, it's something that's very much a feature of, you know, African societies and African cultures. I mean, dating all the way back to, you know, that of Kush, which, you know, existed and was once in modern day Sudan, you know, began in about 5000 BC, ended at about 350 AD. And there was a period from about 200 BC to about 100, 280, where they actually had, you know, female rulers, the Kandankes, who also led, you know, campaigns against the Egyptians, against the Romans. So the most famous is Amani Ranus, who in sort of 26 to 23, 22 BC, fought against the Romans who had just conquered Egypt and were also trying to annex Kush as well. I mean, what's
非洲许多地方的一个特征。是的，绝对是的。我的意思是，女性战斗力量、士兵、军事指挥官，这确实是非洲社会和非洲文化的一个非常显著的特征。我的意思是，一直追溯到库施（Kush）文明，它曾经存在于现代苏丹境内，大约始于公元前5000年，结束于公元350年左右。在公元前200年到公元100年或280年左右的一段时期里，他们实际上有过女性统治者——坎达姬（Kandakes），她们还领导了针对埃及人和罗马人的战役。其中最著名的是阿马尼兰纳斯（Amani Ranas），她在公元前26至23、22年左右，与刚刚征服了埃及并试图兼并库施的罗马人进行了战斗。我的意思是，有趣的是，
interesting, obviously, about the Amazons in sort of the classical Mediterranean is that there's a kind of, you know, there's almost an inbuilt fear because the Amazons of that ilk are basically like an all-female society who don't even allow men to live in their society. Like it's very, it's like what would happen if all the rules of society were completely reversed? And so I'd say one thing I would say is that there's a bit more of a balance in the reality of the African societies. But you can definitely see why that attitude of Amazons, or at least the perception of Amazons, came across to the Europeans who were, or Mediterranean, ancient Mediterranean, whoever, who encountered the female commanders and the female soldiers that existed in numerous African societies and cultures for 2,000 years. So the Amazons have popped up a few times in the Restos history. Alexander the Great was supposed to have met the Amazons.
对于古典地中海时期的亚马逊人来说，显然有一种内在的恐惧，因为那种类型的亚马逊人基本上是一个全女性社会，甚至不允许男性在她们的社会中生活。这就像是如果社会的规则完全颠倒过来会发生什么？因此，我要说的一点是，非洲社会的现实中存在着更多的平衡。但是你绝对可以看出，为什么亚马逊人的那种态度——或者至少是对亚马逊人的看法——会传给那些在2000年里在众多非洲社会和文化中遇到过女性指挥官和女性士兵的欧洲人，或者地中海人、古代地中海人、无论何人。所以亚马逊人在《历史的其余部分》中已经出现过好几次了。亚历山大大帝就被认为曾与亚马逊人会面。
We talked about, in our recent series about Columbus, about how at one point some of the instructions that he has when he goes out are see if you can find where the Amazons are. So when Europeans go to Africa, and obviously all this reflects this kind of fascination this sort of um probably quite heavily sexualized fascination with kind of nubile female warriors and this sort of belief that it's exotic but it's also forbidden it's transgressive and all of this sort of stuff is there any sense i mean i know we're massively
我们在最近关于哥伦布的系列节目中讨论过，他出发时的一些指示之一就是去看看能不能找到亚马逊人的所在地。因此，当欧洲人去到非洲时，很显然，这一切都反映了这种迷恋——这种可能带有浓厚色情色彩的、对充满青春活力的女战士的迷恋，以及这种认为它既异国情调又被禁忌、具有越轨色彩的信念。所有这些东西，有没有这样一种感觉——我知道我们在进行大规模的
generalizing because we're talking about different societies at different points in time. But do you think there's a sense in Africa, as there is in Europe, that female warriors are transgressive, but sort of also sexy, as it were, glamorous? Or is there more of a sense that they're just mundane? They're part of, you know, of course, societies have female warriors. That's completely natural, completely normal. Oh, that's a great question. I would say actually mundane, just because, you know, like I said, in Africa tends to be, it's not just a feature, for example, of the military. It's actually a feature of all of society where you're going to have female counterparts to male positions in society. You know, for example, in Kush, you know, in ancient Kush and actually, you know, even non-societies
概括，因为我们在讨论不同历史时期的不同社会。但你认为在非洲，就像在欧洲一样，人们觉得女战士是越轨的，但同时也有点性感、迷人？还是说人们更多地认为她们其实很普通？她们是……当然，社会拥有女战士，这完全是自然且正常的。哦，这是一个很好的问题。实际上，我会说她们是很普通的。因为，你知道的，就像我说的，在非洲，这往往不仅是军队的一个特征，实际上也是整个社会的特征，在社会中，男性职位总会有相对应的女性职位。你知道，例如在库施，在古代库施，甚至在一些非……社会中，
like the 9th century, Asante, even in Dahomey, there's basically an ideology of duology and dualism, which is essentially that in order for aspects of society to function, you need a male and female counterpart working together. And that's often reflected in the belief systems as well. Usually the main gods of a lot of these African cultures are actually, either they're both male and female. So they're actually of two sexes, or they're of the two sexes fused into one. And it's only by, you know, that connection, that fusion, that actually that God comes into being. So you see it even, for example, in political institutions. So in ancient Kush, from at least the 8th century BC, you, for example, have, you know, the
比如9世纪的阿散蒂（Asante），甚至在达荷美，基本上都存在一种对偶性和二元论的思想。其核心在于，为了让社会的各个方面运转起来，你需要男性和女性的对应部分共同协作。这通常也反映在信仰体系中。这些非洲文化的许多主流神明通常要么既是男性又是女性，即他们实际上具有两种性别，要么是由这两种性别融合为一。只有通过这种连接、这种融合，神明才真正诞生。所以你甚至可以在政治体制中看到这一点。因此，在古代库施，至少从公元前8世纪起，例如，你拥有
institution of the Queen Mother there is very strong. So the king rules, but the Queen Mother, i.e. the mother of the king, is the most important person in the kingdom, even though she's not the one actually in charge of the day-to-day operation of state. And that is the king. And kingship in Kush and in other African societies, in fact, quite a few, is elective, meaning that there's a council who decides who the best prince is, and they make him the leader. And then what happens is that his mother ends up becoming the queen mother and becomes the most powerful person in society. But the king has quite an interesting relationship with his mother and with his wife, and all three are needed. And the wife and the mother represent the female counterpart, and the king and usually the brothers represent the male counterpart, and both are needed in order
那里的王太后制度非常强大。国王进行统治，但王太后（即国王的母亲）是王国中最重要的人物，尽管她并不是实际负责国家日常运作的人，那是国王。而且库施以及其他几个非洲社会的王位继承是选举产生的，这意味着有一个委员会来决定谁是最佳王子，并推选他为领导人。然后发生的事情是，他的母亲最终成为王太后，并成为社会中最具权力的人。但国王与他的母亲和妻子有着非常有趣的关系，这三者都是必需的。妻子和母亲代表了女性的对等部分，而国王通常还有兄弟则代表了男性对等部分，两者的结合对于
to rule the state for it to be functioning effectively. So that goes for the military as well. That goes even for the household. So it pervades all parts of society. But Luke, there are examples, aren't there, also, not just of queen mothers, but of women who rule as queens, who have the rule of an entire people. And you mentioned that you have a particular favorite, don't you? Oh, yeah. She was the first person that you nominated when we started discussing this subject. So this is Nginga of Ndongo. Yes. Have I pronounced that right? So tell us about her because she is, I'm ashamed to say I'd never heard of her, but having read up on her, she really is an amazing figure.
统治国家以使其有效运转都是必不可少的。所以这也适用于军队，甚至适用于家庭。因此，它渗透到社会的各个部分。但是，卢克，也有这样的例子吧，不仅有王太后，还有作为女王统治的女性，她们拥有对整个民族的统治权。你提到过你有一个特别偏爱的人物，对吧？哦，是的。当我们开始讨论这个主题时，你提名第一个人就是她。这就是恩东戈（Ndongo）的恩津加（Nginga）。是的。我发音准确吗？给我们讲讲她，因为她是一个……我很羞愧地说我以前从未听说过她，但在阅读了关于她的资料后，她真的是一个非常了不起的人物。
Yeah, she's quite amazing and really interesting because I think she's, she has this aspect definitely of being heroic because of what she achieved, but actually the brutality that characterised not only her time, but also her rule, you know,
是的，她非常了不起，而且极其有趣，因为我认为她一方面由于她的成就而绝对具有英雄色彩，但另一方面，不仅她的时代，而且她的统治也被残暴所特征化，你知道的，
and things she did sometimes to her own people and also to the Portuguese when we were fighting. Yes. Makes her quite a fascinating figure and, you know. I mean, she's not Jacinda Ardern,
她有时对自己的子民以及在我们战斗时对葡萄牙人做的事情，是的，这使她成为了一个非常迷人的人物，你知道的。我的意思是，她可不是杰辛达·阿恩登（Jacinda Ardern），
is she? No, definitely not. She's 17th century. So she's a 17th century ruler of the Kingdom of Ndongo, which is what was once in northern Angola, what's now northern Angola. And she's actually the first female ruler of that kingdom. So women are treated, you know, actually fairly well in that kingdom, equally in that kingdom. You know, they're not considered property. They can divorce their husbands if they like, go back to their father's family, even elite women.
对吧？不，绝对不是。她是17世纪的人。所以她是17世纪恩东戈王国的统治者，恩东戈王国曾经位于安哥拉北部，也就是现在的安哥拉北部。她实际上是该王国的首位女性统治者。所以女性在这个王国里实际上受到相当好的对待，在这个王国里是平等的。你知道，她们不被视为财产。如果愿意，她们可以与丈夫离婚，回到父亲的家族，即使是精英女性也是如此。
So royal women like Njinga was. So she was part of the royal family of Ndongo, was allowed, and she said was allowed to sit in on the meetings of her father's political councils and military councils, et cetera. But she was actually the first sole female ruler of that kingdom. Because actually female rulers, even though there'd been female ancestresses, there wasn't actually a precedent of a woman being totally in charge of the kingdom. And so she was unique in that regard. But she comes to power in the mid 17th century, but it's really just after the Portuguese have gained quite a strong foothold in West Central Africa. First with the Kingdom of Congo, which is nearby, just northwest
所以像恩津加这样的王室女性也是如此。因此，作为恩东戈王室成员的她，被允许——据说她被允许旁听她父亲的政治委员会和军事委员会等的会议。但她实际上是该王国的首位女性独裁统治者。因为实际上女性统治者，尽管曾有过女性先祖，但并没有女性完全掌控王国的先例。因此在这方面她是独一无二的。但她是在17世纪中期掌权的，当时恰逢葡萄牙人在中西部非洲站稳了脚跟。首先是通过刚果王国，该王国就在附近，位于恩东戈的西北部。
of Ndongo. Yeah, and then with Ndongo itself. And the Ndongon rulers of the late 15th century, early 16th century, are quite keen initially to build relationships with the Portuguese because they see Congo, you know, as also a rival kingdom, gaining goods and power and weaponry, etc. And they want a piece of that. But then afterwards, and this being in the late 16th century, the Portuguese attempt to found a colony in Ndongo, the colony of Angola, because they're making alliances with the king. Sometimes the king, including actually Njinga's grandfather and father, are using them to fight rebellious nobles. But then when the Portuguese, for example, defeat these nobles, sometimes conquering the lands and they fall out with the kings. And then obviously they wanted to found their own colony as well, because they start making inroads deeper into West Central Africa, coming across Congo.
是的，然后是恩东戈本身。15世纪末、16世纪初的恩东戈统治者最初非常热衷于与葡萄牙人建立关系，因为他们将刚果视为一个竞争对手王国，它正在获得货物、权力和武器等，他们也想分一杯羹。但随后，在16世纪末，葡萄牙人试图在恩东戈建立一个殖民地——安哥拉殖民地，因为他们正在与国王结盟。有时国王——包括恩津加的祖父和父亲——利用他们来对付叛乱的贵族。但随后，当葡萄牙人击败了这些贵族（有时征服了土地）时，他们与国王们闹翻了。显然他们也想建立自己的殖民地，因为他们开始向西非中部更深处推进，遇到了刚果。
And this puts them at odds with the rulers of Ndongo. So they fall out as well. And this is really this tense and conflict-ridden period that precedes Njinga's rule. But she's not trained to be queen, is she? She has military training, I think, as a girl, but she doesn't... Yeah. Her brother is king first? Her brother's king first, so yeah. I mean, she did have training and regard
这使他们与恩东戈的统治者产生了矛盾。所以他们也闹翻了。这确实是恩津加统治之前那个充满紧张和冲突的时期。但她并没有受过成为女王的培训，对吧？我记得她作为一个女孩时受过军事训练，但她并没有……是的。她的哥哥先当国王？她的哥哥先当国王，所以是的。我的意思是，她确实接受过训练，因为
because actually she was, you know, as the story goes, she was actually her father's favourite. Right. So N'Gola Ambande is her father. And, you know, she's recognised as being special, as being particularly talented. I mean, she's born in the 1580s in the breech position with her umbilical cord wrapped around her neck. And this
故事是这样的，她实际上是她父亲最宠爱的孩子。没错。恩戈拉·安班德（N'Gola Ambande）是她的父亲。而且，你知道的，她被认为很特别，非常有才华。我的意思是，她出生于1580年代，是臀位出生，脐带绕颈。这
is seen as being an auspicious sign. And when the Mbundu, that's the name of the inhabitants of the kingdom of Ndongo, see her being born in this position, they actually say, oh, my mother, there's a sense that she's destined for greatness. So she's taken really under her father's wing. She's the best at throwing the axe, which is in the axe is like a symbol of Ndongon, you know, authority, rule authority. So her brother hates her, doesn't he? And you can see why. I mean, if you're, your big sister is better at throwing an axe than you are. Oh yeah. No, no, no. So there's a resentment there. I mean, in Gola, so what happens is Mbande Angola is actually
被视为一个吉兆。当姆本杜人（恩东戈王国的居民名称）看到她以这种姿势出生时，他们实际上说：“噢，我的母亲，这意味着她注定要成就伟大事业。”因此她真正受到了父亲的庇护。她是掷斧头最厉害的人，而斧头就像是恩东戈统治权威的象征。所以她哥哥恨她，对吧？你可以理解为什么。如果你是……你的大姐姐比你更会掷斧头。哦，是的。不，不，不。所以这里面存在怨恨。我的意思是，恩戈拉，所以发生的事情是，安班德·恩戈拉实际上
assassinated by his own men. There's a rebellious sober in the north called Gavulo. And the Portuguese are also engaging in conquering activities in the region. And his men and his nobles basically see him as a weak figure. So what they do is they trick him into, they say that their forces need help by a river in the north where the Soba's rebelling. And they take him there and then his own men turn on him and assassinate him. And then what happens after that is there's a power grab by N'Golo Mbande because he really wants to be king. He wants to prove himself to his father and to his people. So, I mean, he just goes on a killing spree.
被他自己的手下暗杀了。北方有一个叛乱的索巴（soba，意为酋长），名叫加武洛（Gavulo）。葡萄牙人也在该地区进行征服活动。他的手下和贵族基本上认为他是一个软弱的人物。所以他们做的是，他们设法欺骗他，说北方有一条河边索巴正在叛乱，他们的军队需要帮助。他们把他带到那里，然后他自己的手下背叛并暗杀了她。在这之后发生的事情是，恩戈拉·恩班德（N'Golo Mbande）进行了权力的争夺，因为他真的很想成为国王。他想向父亲和人民证明自己。所以，我的意思是他简直开启了一场大屠杀。
It's sort of like a 17th century GTA type. He kills everybody. But not N'Jinga, not his sister But not Njinga, not his sister. Not Njinga or his sister. So he has, apart from Njinga, he has two other sisters, Kambu and Fungi. So he doesn't kill them, but he kills Njinga's son, for example.
这有点像17世纪的《侠盗猎车手》（GTA）风格。他杀了所有人。但没有杀恩津加，他的妹妹。但没有杀恩津加，他的妹妹。没有杀恩津加或他的妹妹。所以除了恩津加之外，他还有另外两个妹妹，坎布（Kambu）和丰吉（Fungi）。所以他没有杀她们，但他杀了恩津加的儿子，例如。
Njinga has a baby son with one of her male concubines. God, imagine Christmas. I don't know if he was invited, to be honest. To be honest. I mean, that's an interesting point you raise there, because actually having assassinated him, Njinga goes east. She actually exiles herself to the kingdom of Matamba. And, you know, she's there for quite a few years.
恩津加与她的一位男面首生有一个幼子。天哪，想象一下圣诞节聚会。说实话，我不知道他当时有没有被邀请。说实话。我的意思是，你提出了一个有趣的点，因为实际上在暗杀了那些人之后，恩津加向东走去。她实际上把自己放逐到了马坦巴（Matamba）王国。而且，你知道的，她在那里呆了好几年。
But, you know, he assassinates his uncles and his brothers and their sons. And, I mean, he just kills everybody. He's terrifying. Yeah, no, he is a terrifying figure. I mean, possibly mildly psychopathic. Am I right that he then needs Njinga to come back and negotiate on his behalf with the Portuguese because she can speak Portuguese?
但是，你知道的，他暗杀了他的叔叔们、兄弟们以及他们的儿子们。我的意思是，他杀光了所有人。他太可怕了。是的，不，他是一个可怕的人物。我的意思是，可能有点轻微的精神病倾向。我说的对吗？后来他需要恩津加回来代表他与葡萄牙人谈判，因为她会说葡萄牙语？
She can speak Portuguese, yeah. So is she Christian by this point? No, not by this point. But she's been raised by Portuguese missionaries so she can speak the language. Obviously, you know, the Portuguese were a feature of the Ndongon court. So she has exposure to that. But she's also very proud of her Mbundu heritage. Soongan court, so she has exposure to that,
她会说葡萄牙语，是的。所以她当时已经是基督徒了吗？不，到那时还不是。但她是由葡萄牙传教士抚养长大的，所以她会说这种语言。显然，你知道的，葡萄牙人是恩东戈宫廷的一个特色。所以她接触过这些。但她也为自己的姆本杜血统感到非常自豪。
but she's also very proud of her Mbundu heritage. So you're right, when she's in Matamba, I mean, Ndolomban is failing miserably against the Portuguese. He wanted to keep the integrity of his kingdom and he's just failing. The Portuguese are still conquering and the Portuguese make a deal with these group of marauding militants or former soldiers called Mbangala. They're basically like mercenaries. The Portuguese make a deal with them, and they actually sack the capital of Ndongo, Cabasa, twice. Okay, so that's not going well.
但她也为自己的姆本杜血统感到非常骄傲。所以你说得对，当她在马坦巴时，我的意思是，恩多洛姆班在葡萄牙人面前正一败涂地。他想保持自己王国的完整，但他失败了。葡萄牙人仍在不断征服，他们与一群被称为姆邦加拉的掠夺性武装分子或前士兵达成了协议。他们基本上就像雇佣兵。葡萄牙人与他们达成交易，甚至两次洗劫了恩东戈的首府卡巴萨。好吧，所以事情进展得并不顺利。
Not going well. So anyway, he calls back Njinga from Matamba, not only because she's popular, but because he knows that she also dislikes the Portuguese and wants them out of the region. And like you said, has this exposure to Portuguese culture. She's a lot more worldly than he is. Calls him back, sends him to Luanda, which is obviously now the capital of Angola,
进展不顺利。总之，他把恩津加从马坦巴召回，不仅因为她很受欢迎，还因为他知道她同样讨厌葡萄牙人，并希望他们离开该地区。而且就像你说的，她接触过葡萄牙文化，比他更有见识。他把她召回，派往卢安达——显然现在那是安哥拉的首府，
right on the coast. And that's the Portuguese stronghold, given to them by the Congolese, actually. So that's the Portuguese stronghold. So in 1622, he sends her there to negotiate a deal. And he wants the Portuguese to give back parts of the kingdom to help him against the Mbangala. Because the Mbangala, once they've destroyed the kingdom,
就在海岸边。那是葡萄牙人的据点，实际上是刚果人送给他们的。所以那是葡萄牙人的大本营。因此在1622年，他派她去那里谈判一项协议。他希望葡萄牙人归还王国的一部分土地，以帮他对抗姆邦加拉人。因为姆邦加拉人在摧毁了王国之后，
they just leave the Portuguese and they go back and sack it again. They don't take orders from anybody. So he wants their help. And actually, when you mentioned Christianity, it's as part of this negotiation in exchange for Portuguese support and peace that Njinga agrees to be baptized. She takes the name Ana de Souza and has a Catholic godmother and is baptized as part of that deal. When she goes to do these negotiations,
他们只是离开葡萄牙人，然后回去再次洗劫。他们不听从任何人的命令。所以他需要他们的帮助。实际上，当你提到基督教时，恩津加同意受洗就是这次谈判的一部分，以此换取葡萄牙的支持与和平。她取名为安娜·德·索萨，有一位天主教教母，作为那项交易的一部分受洗。当她去进行这些谈判时，
the Portuguese are all sitting down and they don't give her a chair. And so she orders an attendant and sits on the attendant. Is that story true? That is true. Yeah, yeah. That's very regal behavior. Yeah. There's even an engraving of it, which is really interesting. You can see images, you know, because it's definitely one of the most sort of engaging moments. But that's true. I mean, whenever the Portuguese conquered the nobles, so the nobles called sobers, whenever they conquered them and made them sign, you know, submission pleasures, afterwards and even during the pleasure used to make them sit on the floor, whereas the
葡萄牙人全都坐着，却没有给她一把椅子。于是她命令一个随从，坐在了随从身上。这个故事是真的吗？那是真的。对，对。那是极具王者风范的行为。对。甚至还有一幅版画，真的很有趣。你能看到那些画面，你知道的，因为这绝对是最吸引人的时刻之一。但这是真的。我的意思是，每当葡萄牙人征服了贵族——那些被称为索伯斯的贵族，每当他们征服他们并让他们签署，你知道的，臣服誓约时，在那之后甚至在宣誓期间，他们习惯于让他们坐在地板上，而
Portuguese governor used to sit on this gold embroidered velvet chair. So it was to reinforce and also act as a symbol of that submission. And then they try to do the same to Njinga because they want her to sign the submission deal. And they don't give her a chair. And she calls over one of her female attendants to make a chair. She just sort of goes down on her hands and knees. And Njinga sits on her and apparently conducts the negotiation for hours just in that position. This is promising that she's going to be a great queen. I mean, this is very much the kind of behavior you want. So her brother dies and she becomes queen. Yeah. And then what happens? So her brother dies, she becomes queen. She's always trying to, you know, she engages in a policy of trying to make peace first rather than war. I mean,
葡萄牙总督则坐在金绣天鹅绒椅子上。所以这是为了强化并充当这种臣服的象征。然后他们试图对恩津加做同样的事，因为他们想让她签署臣服协议。他们不给她椅子。于是她叫来自己的一名女侍从当椅子。那个侍从就跪在地上，恩津加坐在她身上，据说就这样保持那个姿势进行了几个小时的谈判。这预示着她将成为一位伟大的女王。我的意思是，这非常符合你所期望的那种行为。所以她的哥哥死了，她成了女王。对。然后发生了什么？所以她哥哥死了，她成了女王。她一直在试图，你知道的，她采取的是先谋求和平而不是战争的政策。我的意思是，
so she's actually trying to reach out to the Portuguese, but she's very keen on not submitting to them. So she's trying to engage in deals with the Portuguese governors, and they're having none of it. So it's actually after that that she initiates a rebellion against the Portuguese. She sends her messengers into all of the air, basically the Portuguese plantations in West Central Africa. So they have people working there and tells them,
所以她实际上正试图向葡萄牙人伸出橄榄枝，但她非常坚持不向他们臣服。因此她试图与葡萄牙总督进行交易，而他们根本不买账。实际上正是在那之后，她发起了针对葡萄牙人的叛乱。她把信使派往所有地区，基本上就是西中非的葡萄牙种植园。他们在那里有人劳作，她告诉他们，
her messengers tell them that she's standing up to the Portuguese and that they need to support her. There's a period of maybe 20 or 30 years where she's essentially trying to make peace with the Portuguese, failing, then battling with them. The Portuguese are pursuing her, you know, on different islands, on a stronghold. And, you know, she's trying to remain one step ahead of them, trying to engage in peace. But, you know, it's essentially, you know, conflict ridden few decades against the Portuguese as she's trying to maintain the integrity of the kingdom of Ndonga. And then how does she get involved with, is it Kassanje? Kassanje, yeah, the Mbangala. So as I mentioned, there's this back and forth conflict. Actually,
她的信使告诉他们，她正在对抗葡萄牙人，他们需要支持她。有一段大约20到30年的时间，她基本上在试图与葡萄牙人和解，失败了，然后与他们战斗。葡萄牙人在追捕她，你知道的，在不同的岛屿上，在据点里。而且，你知道的，她试图保持领先他们一步，试图进行和平谈判。但是，你知道的，在试图维护恩东戈王国的完整时，这基本上是充满冲突的几十年。然后她是怎么和……是卡桑杰扯上关系的？卡桑杰，对，那些姆邦加拉人。所以正如我所提到的，这里有这种来回的冲突。实际上，
she makes a deal with Kassanje after a major loss of the Portuguese. She loses terribly to the Portuguese in the late 60s and 20s. And, you know, her forces have been decimated and she needs more soldiers. So she makes a deal with this Mbangala leader called Kisanjan as part of the deal. She not only has to give up her symbols of all authority and agree to marry him,
在对葡萄牙人遭遇重大惨败之后，她与卡桑杰达成了一项协议。她在60年代末和20年代惨败给葡萄牙人。而且，你知道的，她的军队已经被消灭殆尽，她需要更多的士兵。所以她与这位名叫基桑詹的姆邦加拉领袖达成了协议，作为协议的一部分，她不仅要交出所有的权力象征并同意嫁给他，
but she also has to become an Mbangala herself. So she goes through the rituals to become an Mbangala. And that's a colossal deal. Big deal, Huge deal. That's giving up her own cultural heritage to embrace that of their traditional enemies, right? Yeah. I mean, I wouldn't consider the Mbangala to be their traditional enemies per se, but it's definitely contrary to Mbundu custom. You're totally right in that regard. I mean, the Mbangala
而且她还必须自己变成一个姆邦加拉人。所以她经历了成为姆邦加拉人的各种仪式。这是一笔极其巨大的交易。大交易，巨大的交易。那是放弃她自己的文化传统去拥抱他们传统敌人的文化，对吧？对。我的意思是，我不认为姆邦加拉人可以说是他们的传统敌人，但它绝对违背了姆布杜的风俗。在这方面你完全是对的。我的意思是，姆邦加拉人
are lawless, like, you know, for the most part. You know, they live by pillaging and, you know, and some of the things that she has to do, or Elisa said is that she has to do in the Mbangala camp, including, you know, a blood oath ceremony where she has to drink the blood of the Mbangala and that kind of thing, run very contrary to Mbundu customs, exactly like you say.
基本上是无法无天的，你知道的。他们靠劫掠为生，你知道的，而且她必须在姆邦加拉营地做的一些事情或伊丽莎说她必须做的事情，包括血誓仪式，她必须喝姆邦加拉人的血之类的事情，正如你所说，这与姆布杜的风俗背道而驰。
Just a quick question on that. So I was reading about that, that she drinks human blood. She has to use some sort of oil made from a slain baby or something. Yeah. Crushed baby, one of her attendants. Yeah. Right. And is that stuff just projection and fantasy or did that really happen? You know, it's so difficult to say. I mean, given the brutality of the Mbangala, I'm not,
关于这一点我有个简短的问题。我当时读到关于她的资料时说她喝人血。她还得用某种从被杀害的婴儿身上提取的油之类的东西。对。被压碎的婴儿，她的一名侍从。对。没错。那些事情只是投射和幻想还是真的发生过？你知道，这太难说了。鉴于姆邦加拉人的残暴，我不，
you know, I don't know if I would rule it completely out. One thing I would say is that whether or not it was a European invention is something different. It could be a Portuguese invention, but then again, I wouldn't necessarily blame Portuguese. It could actually be something that the Mbangala either say themselves, because their whole thing was about to inspire fear in peoples around the place. So it could either be from them or it's metaphorical. They're different explanations, but it could actually be a real thing. Because no jenga seems to be an absolute liberal and absolutely worse so so um she goes to war with the kingdom of matamba oh yeah is that right and she conquers them and takes the queen captive yeah more longer yeah and so she should properly put the queen to death but instead she it's very liberal democrat behavior she just
你知道，我不知道我是不是会完全排除这种可能。我要说的一点是，这究竟是不是欧洲人的发明则是另一回事。这可能是葡萄牙人的发明，但话又说回来，我未必会责怪葡萄牙人。这实际上可能是姆邦加拉人自己说的话，因为他们的整套行事方式就是为了在各地的人民中间激起恐惧。所以这要么来自他们，要么是隐喻。有不同的解释，但它实际上可能是真的。因为恩津加似乎是个绝对的自由派而且更糟糕……所以她向马坦巴王国宣战了，哦，是吗？她征服了他们并俘虏了女王？是的，莫隆加，是的。所以她本该处死女王，但相反她——这是非常自由民主的行为，她只是
brands her oh tom that's just that's snowflakery, isn't it? Absolute snowflakery. Absolutely. I mean, especially this time, yeah. Absolutely. And takes her daughters into service as her warriors. Yes, yes. Well, yeah, she adopts her daughter. You're right.
给她的脸上烙了印，哦，汤姆，那简直是“雪花”行为，对吧？绝对的“雪花”行为。绝对是。我的意思是，特别是在那个时候，对吧。绝对的。并且把她的女儿们收编为她的女战士。是的，是的。好吧，是的，她收养了她的女儿。你说得对。
Doesn't slay Mwanga, the queen of Mentamba. Brands her and sends her into exile to rule another part of the kingdom, which she does shortly after. Snowflakery. Yeah, so frank. But I think it's partly because she has a reverence for for royalty i think that was actually it to be honest okay so it's like elizabeth the first not wanting to kill mary queen of scots exactly exactly i think it's
没有杀死马坦巴女王姆旺加。而是给她烙印并将她流放到王国的另一个部分去统治，她不久后确实这么做了。“雪花”行为。对，真坦率。但我想这部分是因为她对皇室怀有一种敬意，我认为这才是真正的真相，老实说。好吧，所以这就像伊丽莎白一世不想处死苏格兰女王玛丽一样，完全如此，完全如此，我认为这是
not spilling royal blood yeah so at this point is she ruling very much as a queen i as an identifiably female monarch or is she you know doing that thing where she's ruling as a queen, i.e. as an identifiably female monarch? Or is she doing that thing where she's ruling as a king, but she just happens to be a queen, if you know what I mean? So in other words, does she dress and behave as a man or as a woman? That's a good question. She definitely doesn't shy away from being feminine in certain regards. Like I said, she has tons of male concubines, et cetera. But then there is also that behavior where she makes her, some of her male concubines, dress up as women and then acts as a man. So it's part of- Right. And her bodyguard is female. So her soldiers are female and her concubines are male. And there's kind of full-scale cross-dressing going on.
不流淌皇室之血。对，所以在这时，她是以一个女王的身份在统治吗？作为一个身份明确的女君主？还是说她在做那种事——作为一个女王在统治，也就是作为一个身份明确的女君主？还是说她在做那种事：她以国王的身份统治，但她恰好是个女王，如果你懂我的意思？换句话说，她是以男人的打扮和行为举止行事，还是像个女人？这是个好问题。她在某些方面绝对没有回避女性特质。就像我说的，她有成群的男面首等等。但同时也有那种行为：她让她的某些男面首打扮成女人，然后自己表现得像个男人。所以这是——没错。而且她的保镖是女性。所以她的士兵是女性，她的面首是男性。那里可以说是全方位的易装行为。
I mean, she has, yeah, like you said, close female attendants and generals and all the rest of it. Who exactly those were, we're not sure. But she also has female concubines. But then also that wasn't unusual in terms of, you know, women being allowed to have relationships with multiple men. And especially if they're royal women, you see it in other places as well. Right. Yeah. And so what's happening with Cassandre, meanwhile? Because he doesn't seem the kind of guy who would necessarily be happy with his wife keeping large numbers of men dressed as women. Yeah, with concubines.
我的意思是，她有，是的，就像你说的，亲近的女侍从、将军以及其他所有人。这些人具体是谁，我们并不确定。但她也有女面首。不过在女性被允许与多个男人交往这方面，那也并不罕见。特别是如果她们是皇室女性的话，你在其他地方也能看到这种现象。对。没错。那么与此同时，卡桑杰那边情况如何？因为他看起来不像是那种会对自己的妻子养着大量打扮成女人的男人感到高兴的人。是的，还有面首。
Yeah, I mean, Cassandra himself has, you know, says he has up to like 30 sons or something. He's a lad. So, I mean, he's probably busy. He's probably busy himself. But that's true. But how are they getting on? Are they still a fixture? Yeah, I mean, there's still a, you know, an alliance between them. How strong this is after
是的，我的意思是，卡桑杰自己，你知道的，说过他有多达30个儿子左右。他是个风流人物。所以，我的意思是，他可能很忙。他自己可能就很忙。但这是真的。不过他们相处得怎么样？他们之间还是稳固的盟友吗？是的，我的意思是，他们之间仍然存在，你知道的，一种联盟关系。在经历了
the conquest of, because she's still using, you know, in Bangala forces, she uses them to conquer, you know, to conquer Matamba. I mean, you know, afterwards, Cassandre also wants to found his own kingdom, actually. So he's sort of getting closer with the Portuguese. So there does seem to be a freezing of relations between them, but she's still relying on his quote-unquote manpower. And so she, what is it, going into the kind of the 1630s, she becomes more and more powerful. Yeah. She enters into an alliance with the Dutch. She starts supplying them with slaves. Well, that's an interesting point, isn't it? Because that goes back to that thing we were
征服之后，这种联盟有多强？因为她仍然在使用，你知道的，姆邦加拉军队，她用他们来征服，你知道的，征服马坦巴。我的意思是，你知道的，在那之后，卡桑杰实际上也想建立他自己的王国。所以他跟葡萄牙人的关系变得更亲密了。因此他们之间的关系似乎确实出现了冷却，但她仍然依赖他的所谓“兵力”。所以她，是怎么回事，进入1630年代后，她变得越来越强大。是的。她与荷兰人结盟。她开始向他们供应奴隶。嗯，这是一个有趣的观点，不是吗？因为这回到了我们刚刚
talking about at the beginning about the... The Dahomey. Yeah, the Dahomey, the warriors of Dahomey. So she is slave-taking. That's a pretty established military practice, is it, for that kingdom? Yes, but I think when it comes to Africa, obviously there's two kinds. So the slavery that's happening in Africa, i.e. the types of people that Nginga herself has in her service, are probably better described as serfs. Now, this is not to suggest that it's fine, but also that Africans aren't, you know,
在开始时谈论的关于……达荷美。是的，达荷美，达荷美的战士。所以她在捕捉奴隶。对于那个王国来说，这是一项相当成熟的军事惯例，是吗？是的，但我觉得说到非洲，显然有两种。所以发生在非洲的奴隶制，也就是说恩津加本人手下那些人的类型，或许用农奴来形容更贴切。这并不是说这就很好，但也并非非洲人没有，你知道的，
enslaving people too seldom to, you know, for example, you know, knowing full well that they're going to be traded across the Atlantic. But actually what's happening in Africa and the reason Njinga is angry, for example, with the Portuguese is because they're enslaving largely as well free Mbundu citizens. So that's an issue. And so by building this alliance with the Dutch, and she's got her terrifying husband as well, she's able to essentially to rebuild the power of her own people. And she ends up able to essentially kind of reconstitute it and to establish peace treaty with the portuguese is that right yeah yeah but i mean she she makes an alliance with the dutch but the dutch actually
奴役人们太少，你知道的，比如，心知肚明这些人将被跨大西洋贩卖。但实际上在非洲发生的事情以及恩津加生气的理由，例如她对葡萄牙人生气，是因为他们很大程度上也在奴役自由的姆布杜公民。所以这是一个问题。因此，通过与荷兰人建立这种联盟，而且她身边还有她那可怕的丈夫，她基本上能够重建她自己人民的力量。她最终能够基本上将其重组，并与葡萄牙人达成和平条约，是吗？对，对。但我的意思是，她与荷兰人结盟，但荷兰人实际上
let her down so this is in the 1640s and she agrees to supply oh well so off from the way with the dutch tom so off from the way you know they they form an alliance in the 1640s and they're supposed to storm you know luanda make it up but what happens is the portuguese send reinforcements from south america and they start bombarding because the Dutch have taken Luanda. Oh, so this is all part of the First World War, Dominic. It's a Tom's theory, Luke. Yeah, the Dutch-Portuguese war, global war. Yes. Exactly. It's all part of the Dutch coming into and taking, you know, the Atlantic trade from the, you know, from the Portuguese.
让她失望了，所以这是在1640年代，她同意供应——哦，好吧，所以别扯远了，汤姆，关于荷兰人的事。别扯远了，你知道的，他们在1640年代结盟，他们本应该突袭，你知道的，卢安达，夺下它，但发生的事情是葡萄牙人从南美洲派遣了增援部队，并开始进行轰炸，因为荷兰人已经占领了卢安达。哦，所以这一切都是第一次世界大战的一部分，多米尼克。这是汤姆的理论，卢克。对，荷葡战争，全球战争。是的。完全正确。这都是荷兰人进入并从葡萄牙人手中夺取大西洋贸易的一部分。
But also in South America as well. I mean, they take, you know, the sugar producing regions of Northeast Brazil. But Nginga is able to capitalize on it, basically. Yeah, she's able to capitalize on it. But like I said, they make a deal to storm the capital. And essentially, when it looks hopeless, the Dutch go ahead to Luanda and board ships and take off whilst Nginga is waiting for the order, or at least for them to make their assault, their combined assault on the capital. So then she has to try other strategies. So what she does is, again, she does this sort of, I mean, two, three-pronged strategy, really. So from Matamba, which is before she conquers Matamba, she's essentially a guerrilla. She's engaging in guerrilla warfare. She doesn't
而且在南美洲也是如此。我的意思是，他们占领了巴西东北部的产糖区。但恩津加能够利用这一点，基本上是这样。是的，她能够利用这一点。但就像我说的，他们达成协议去突袭首府。基本上，当看起来毫无希望时，荷兰人径直前往卢安达登船逃跑了，而恩津加还在等待命令，或者至少在等待他们发起进攻，对首府发起联合进攻。所以她不得不尝试其他策略。所以她做的是，再次重申，她采用了某种，我的意思是，两到三管齐下的策略，真的。所以从马坦巴——这是在她征服马坦巴之前，她基本上是个游击队员。她在进行游击战。她
actually have a base until she captures Matamba after instigating the rebellion. But she engages quite a lot with the Capuchin missionaries, and she writes to the Pope, and she tries to get recognised as a Christian monarch. That's one big thing that she does. And does that work? It does. Yeah, yeah, it does. The Capuchins, because they're very keen to start missionary work in Ndongo, and they want her to give up the traditional practices, the Mbangala rites. So her state starts to become, she starts to Christianise. Is that right starts to become, she starts to Christianize. Is that right? Yeah. So she starts to Christianize. Probably, I would say, I mean, it's always hard to say because obviously, like I said, she becomes baptized in the 1620s,
实际上没有根据地，直到她在挑起叛乱后攻占了马坦巴。但她与嘉布遣会传教士有很多接触，她给教皇写信，试图被承认为一个基督教君王。那是她做的重大举措之一。这起作用了吗？起作用了。对，对，起作用了。嘉布遣会士，因为他们非常渴望在恩东戈开展传教工作，他们希望她放弃传统习俗，即姆邦加拉仪式。所以她的国家开始变成，她开始基督教化。是这样吗，开始变成，她开始基督教化。是这样吗？对。所以她开始基督教化。可能吧，我想说，当然很难说，因为显然，正如我所说，她在1620年代受洗，
but definitely in the 50s, particularly 1650s, 1660s, she Christianizes, but she's also launching attacks against Ndongo because the Portuguese have installed a puppet king there. So she's launching attacks against him, putting on the military pressure. She's closing the slave markets. The Portuguese are relying on to supply their plantations in Brazil. And she's also trying to reach a diplomatic conclusion. So she's actually done all of these things. That's why she's renowned as a very capable leader. Her strategic mind is unbelievable. So she's doing all these things at once in order to bring the Portuguese to the negotiating table. But at this time, they also have her sister Cambu in captivity as well. So she's keen to get her back. So they capture her a few years before. And one of her sisters actually has been drowned by the Portuguese also having been captured. Because she's sending,
但绝对是在50年代，特别是1650年代、1660年代，她实现了基督教化，但她同时也对恩东戈发起了攻击，因为葡萄牙人在那里扶植了一个傀儡国王。所以她一直在对她发起攻击，施加军事压力。她正在关闭葡萄牙人赖以供应他们在巴西的种植园的奴隶市场。她还试图通过外交途径解决问题。所以她实际上把所有这些事都做了。这就是为什么她被誉为一位非常能干的领袖。她的战略头脑简直令人难以置信。所以她同时在做所有这些事情，以便迫使葡萄牙人坐到谈判桌前。但在此时，他们还把她的妹妹坎布作为人质扣押着。所以她急于把她救回来。因为他们几年前俘虏了她。而且她的另一个妹妹实际上也被葡萄牙人淹死了，也是在被俘后。因为她在派出，
Fungi's sending letters. She's in Portuguese captivity and she's sending letters to Njinga via secret spy network, telling her about Portuguese captivity and she's sending letters to Njinga via secret spy network, telling her about Portuguese movements and the Portuguese discover these and execute her. So only one sister remains. So one part of the reason she does this as well, especially after the Dutch failure, is to really bring the Portuguese to the negotiating table because she wants her sister back. It works at the end. All of her strategies sort of converge. I mean, her military one was probably the main thing, you know, the overseas council, you know, basically
丰吉在写信。她被葡萄牙人俘虏了，通过秘密间谍网给恩津加写信，告诉她葡萄牙人的动向，结果被葡萄牙人发现并处决了。所以只剩下一个妹妹了。她这么做的一个原因，特别是在荷兰人失败之后，是真正把葡萄牙人逼上谈判桌，因为她想要回自己的妹妹。最后成功了。她所有的策略都汇聚到了一起。我的意思是，她的军事策略可能主要体现在，你知道的，海外委员会基本上
tell the Portuguese governors to behave themselves. They're like, you're spending so many resources fighting this one woman and we're losing money hand over fist, you know, end it. They're like, please stop. So that is actually, I think it's actually a military, you know, activities in particular, and the fact that she's open to peace that brings the Portuguese to the negotiating table in the early to mid 1660s. So it works, her strategy works. It works. I mean, and, and, you know, they sign a deal, the Portuguese in the initial contract, because there's a bit of a back and forth between what the terms are going to be, you know, contracts and deals go. And, you know, the Portuguese initially want to put in the treaty
告诉葡萄牙总督们规矩点。他们觉得，你们花这么多资源跟这一个女人打仗，我们正亏得血本无归，你知道的，结束吧。他们说，求求你们停手吧。所以，我认为这实际上是军事行动，特别是她的和平意愿，在17世纪60年代初将葡萄牙人带上了谈判桌。所以它起作用了，她的策略起作用了。起作用了。我的意思是，而且，你知道的，他们签署了一项协议，葡萄牙人在最初的合同中——因为关于条款内容有一些来回拉锯，你知道合同和协议就是这样——你知道，葡萄牙人最初想在条约中加入
that she has to supply slaves, like a tribute of slaves every year to the Portuguese king. And she asked them to take that out. I mean, not because, you know, again, not because she's like woke, not because she's anti-slavery per se, but because that would mean that Ndongo is a vassal, you know, is a summit estate to the Portuguese so she asks them to take them out and the Portuguese do and actually she gains back most of, you know, the original kingdom of Ndongo and is recognised as the queen
规定她必须提供奴隶，就像每年向葡萄牙国王进贡奴隶一样。她要求他们删掉这一条。我的意思是，不是因为，呃，再次强调，不是因为她有什么“觉醒”意识，也不是因为她本身反对奴隶制，而是因为那意味着恩东戈是一个附庸国，你知道的，是葡萄牙的属地，所以她要求他们删掉，葡萄牙人照办了。事实上，她夺回了大部分，你知道的，恩东戈王国的领土，并被承认为了
of Matamba. But then comes to a very pathetic end. She dies of a throat infection. Yeah, dies of a throat but she's old, this is the thing. But she dies in her bed doesn't she? I mean that's an amazing feat for a warrior queen. She's 75 she's been fighting as a the thing. But she dies in her bed, doesn't she? I mean, that's an amazing feat for a warrior queen. She's 75. She's been fighting as a Portuguese for 60 years.
马坦巴的女王。但随后却迎来了非常悲惨的结局。她死于喉部感染。是的，死于咽喉……但她老了，关键在于这。但她死在自己的床上，不是吗？我的意思是，对于一个战士女王来说，这是一个了不起的壮举。她75岁了，一直在战斗……关键在于这。但她死在自己的床上，不是吗？我的意思是，对于一个战士女王来说，这是一个了不起的壮举。她75岁了。她与葡萄牙人作战了60年。
75. Wow. That's pretty good going. That is good going. A large part of which she's been in the field. You know, in fact, what she says, she thanks her soldiers after the peace is affected. One of the things she said is, I'm tired.
75岁。哇。那真的很了不起。这真的很了不起。其中很大一部分时间她都在战场上。你知道的，事实上，她所说的，她在实现和平后感谢了她的士兵。她说过的一句话是，我累了。
Like, I've been doing this for 60 years. I've been in the field. I'm an old woman. I just want to live with my sister in peace. Like Tom after a podcast. Exactly. What an amazing woman. And thanks so much for introducing me to her. I'm very ashamed I've never heard of her.
就像，我干这个已经60年了。我一直在战场上。我已经是个老太婆了。我只想和我的妹妹过平静的生活。就像播客结束后的汤姆一样。没错。多么了不起的女性啊。非常感谢你向我介绍她。我很惭愧我以前从未听说过她。
Doesn't she appear in the Marquis de Sade, Tom? Yeah, she does, I think. He claimed that she had 50 to 60 men dressed as women in her harem. Yeah. And they had to fight to the death for the privilege and duty of spending the night with her. Right. Okay. I don't know about the second, but the first part's true true people say that about cleopatra and stuff as well right that was brilliant so i think we can definitely notch her up as an african amazon let's take a break now and then when we come back we'll look at the
她难道没有出现在萨德侯爵的作品里吗，汤姆？对，她确实出现过，我想是的。他声称她的后宫里有50到60个打扮成女人的男人。是的。他们必须为了获得和她过夜的特权和职责而战至死。好吧。好吧。第二个我不知道，但第一部分是真的。人们对克利奥帕特拉等人也这么说，对吧？太精彩了，所以我觉得我们绝对可以把她归为非洲亚马逊人。我们现在休息一下，等回来后，我们将探讨
dahomey warriors but also we'll look at some uh amazons who are very close to your heart the ashanti queen mothers because you are ashanti aren't you yes to your heart, the Ashanti Queen Mothers, because you are Ashanti, aren't you? Yes, indeed. And the Ashanti are very much friends of the show. We did an episode on them. So when we come back, the Ashanti Queen Mothers. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman.
达荷美战士，同时我们还会看看一些……呃，对你来说意义非凡的亚马逊人——阿散蒂王太后，因为你就是阿散蒂人，对吧？是的……对你来说意义非凡的阿散蒂王太后，因为你就是阿散蒂人，对吧？是的，确实如此。而且阿散蒂人可以说是本节目的老朋友了。我们曾为他们做过一期节目。所以等我们回来，我们将聚焦阿散蒂王太后。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。
And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. She might have been anywhere between 40 and 50, rather round-faced, with a small straight nose, a fine brow and a short broad-lipped mouth. Her skin was jet black and plump. And then you met the eyes, and in a sudden chill rush of fear realised that all you had heard was true,
我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论以及少许八卦。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家播客以及现场门票的优先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。她可能在40到50岁之间，脸盘较圆，鼻子小而直，眉毛秀气，嘴唇较宽。她的皮肤漆黑而丰满。然后你迎上了她的眼神，在一阵突如其来的恐惧寒意中，你意识到你所听闻的一切都是真的，
and the horrors you had seen needed no further explanation. They were small and bright and evil as a snake's, unblinking with a depth of cruelty and malice that was terrifying. So Tom and Luke Pepper, you will of course know that that comes from one of our very best sources on 19th century Africa, the papers of Sir Harry Flashman, who in the novel Flashman's Lady by George MacDonald Fraser, he pitches up at the court of Rana Valona, the mad monarch of Madagascar. A tremendous figure. We'll come to her in just a second. But Luke, you are talking us through African queens and African Amazons, African female warriors.
而你所见过的恐怖景象也无需过多的解释。它们的眼睛又小又亮，像蛇一样邪恶，冷酷无情，散发着一种令人毛骨悚然的残酷和恶意。所以汤姆和卢克·佩珀，你们当然知道这出自我们关于19世纪非洲最好的资料之一——哈里·弗莱什曼爵士的文件。在乔治·麦克唐纳·弗莱什曼的小说《弗莱什曼夫人的仕途》（Flashman's Lady）中，他来到了拉纳瓦洛娜的宫廷——马达加斯加疯狂君主的宫廷。一个了不起的人物。我们稍后就会谈到她。但卢克，你要给我们讲讲非洲女王和非洲亚马逊人、非洲女战士。
And we were promised that you would talk about Ashanti Queen Mothers who apparently for whom you have a tendresse I believe. Yes yes so I'm Ashanti myself and you know this is one of the first things that I got into especially when researching African history and I even know of Ashanti Queen Mothers myself on my paternal grandmother's side so very close to my heart indeed. And so what's so unique about ashanti queen mothers what makes them distinctive so this is ghana isn't it this is the kind of great kingdom 17th century right the way up to the colonial period exactly so now we're looking at modern day ghana and the ashanti empire founded in the early early 18th century and they have a golden stool don't they
而且我们之前说好你要谈谈阿散蒂王太后，据说你对她们情有独钟。对，对，所以其实我自己就是阿散蒂人，你知道的，这是我最初接触的领域之一，尤其是在研究非洲历史的时候，我甚至在我 paternal grandmother（祖母）那边的家族里就认识阿散蒂王太后，所以这对我来说确实非常亲近。那么阿散蒂王太后有什么独特之处呢？是什么让她们如此与众不同？所以这是加纳，对吧？这是一个伟大的王国，从17世纪一直延续到殖民时期，对吧？完全正确，所以我们现在看到的是现代加纳和在18世纪初建立的阿散蒂帝国，他们有一把金凳，对吧？
which is the golden stool exactly the symbol of the Ashanti and, you know, an axe as the king's throne, although it's not actually allowed to, nobody's allowed to sit on it, always kept on its side. But Ashanti is unique. Well, actually probably not unique, I would say, but it's definitely very unusual, you know, even in Africa, actually,
也就是金凳，没错，它是阿散蒂的象征，还有一把作为国王王座的斧头，尽管它实际上不允许——没有人被允许坐在上面，它总是侧放着。但阿散蒂是独特的。好吧，其实可能也不是独特的，我想说，但它绝对非常不寻常，你知道的，甚至在非洲也是如此，
for being both a matriarchal and a matrilineal society. So women rule the roost, you know, in all kinds of ways. And the queen mother is the most important political figure in the Ashanti authority. So that is what's quite unusual about it, is that we have this one figure who has a say
因为它既是一个母系社会，又是一个母系继承社会。所以女性在各方面都掌握着主导权。而王太后是阿散蒂政权中最具政治重要的人物。所以这才是相当不同寻常的地方，那就是我们有这样一位女性，她在社会的许多方面都有发言权，并且在非洲乃至世界的许多社会中拥有无与伦比的权力。而且一个阿散蒂人的一切都与他们的母亲息息相关。但王太后是阿散蒂黑尼（Asantehene，阿散蒂国王）的母亲。那么，在众位王太后中，哪一位最受推崇、最具军事才华呢？很可能是亚·阿散蒂娃（Yaa Asantewaa），她在早期对抗英国人，爆发了金凳之战。这是一场伟大的战争，这是一场伟大的战争，因为当英国人要求阿散蒂交出金凳时，她拒绝交出，你知道的，最终在流亡中失败了……
in so many aspects of society and who has power unrivaled in a lot of the societies in Africa, but also of the world. And everything that an Ashanti person is is connected to their mother. But the queen mother is the mother of the Asante Hine, the Asante king. And so who is the most celebrated, the most marshaly proficient of the queen mothers? Probably Ya Asante Wa, who fought against the British in the early, the War of the Golden Stool. It's a great war it's a great war because she refused to give up the golden stool when it was demanded of the Ashanti by the British and you know actually ends up losing in his exile
被流亡到塞舌尔，但你知道的，她挺身而出，因为许多阿散蒂国王，你知道的，他们实际上与英国人的关系相当不错，所以他们并不热衷于战斗，而她，你知道的，痛斥了他们，说，你们这些软弱的男人，这在你们祖先的时代是不会发生的，诸如此类的话，然后领导了对他们的抵抗。所以她可能……所以这是19世纪末，对吧？19世纪末，20世纪初。
to to the Seychelles but you know she stood up because a lot of the Ashanti kings you know they actually had quite good relationships with the British so they weren't keen to fight and she you know lambasted them and said, you know, you weak men, and this wouldn't happen in the time of your ancestors and all that kind of thing, and then leads a resistance against them. So she's probably... So this is the end of the 19th century, is it? End of the 19th century, early 20th.
她可能是最广为人知、最受尊敬的。所以很多芒加人（Montgarnens），实际上包括我自己的妹妹在内，都是以她命名的，都叫雅·乔瓦（Ya Jowar），那是她的名字，后来当她获得头衔成为王太后时，就被称为雅·阿散蒂娃（Yaa Asantewaa）。那么作为王太后，你拥有指挥权吗？你掌握着生杀大权吗？诸如此类的事情？永生，真的吗？是的，好问题。我的意思是，其实你拥有最多的。所以这更像是一种王权背后的权力结构。所以国王统治，就像刚才我们谈到库施时一样，差不多就是那种情况，但女王决定，对谁将成为国王拥有最终决定权。因此，阿散蒂的王位也是
She's probably the best known and the most revered as well. So a lot of Montgarnens, including my own sister, in fact, are named after her, are called Y Jowar, which was her name, and then Yaa Santowar when she obtained her title when she became Queen Mother. And so as the Queen Mother, do you have the power of command? Do you wield the power of life and death? Any of these kinds of things? Immortality, true. Yeah, good question. I mean, what you most have actually. So it's a more kind of power behind the throne type situation. So the king rules, I mean, talking about Kush earlier, it's sort of that kind of situation, but the queen decides, has the final say on who the king is going to be. So kingship and Asante is also
选举产生的。并且实际上有一个长老会，即布苏萨奇里（Bususa Chiri），负责决定下一任国王。其成员来自政治、军事或其他各个领域的各阶层。但如果他们选择了一个王太后不满意的人，她可以行使否决权。她是唯一有权力否决该决定的人。而且她是唯一能够向阿散蒂黑尼（Asantehene）下达指令的人，哪怕当着他的参赞和谋士的面也可以。基本上就是“别躲在卧室里”。是的，是的，是的。基本上就是这样。她是唯一能向他下达指令的人。事实上，当国王在议会中就座时，她就站在他右侧的后方。这样一来，如果她受到任何形式的威胁，比如弓箭或长矛，
elected. And there's actually a council of elders, the Bususa Chiri, who decides on the next king. And the people from all matters of the spectrum in terms of being from politics, from military or wherever. But if they choose someone with whom the Queen Mother is not happy, she can veto. She's the only one who has power to veto that decision. And she's the only one who can order the Asante Hine, even in front of his councillors and his advisors, can give him instructions. Don't hide in your bedroom. Essentially. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Essentially. She's the only one who can give him instructions. And in fact, she stands, you know, when King is, you know, is seated in council, she is to his right, just behind him. And that's so that if she's threatened in any way, a bow and arrow spear,
他实际上可以飞身扑到她前面保护她。所以她拥有难以置信的精神、象征和政治权威，但她实际上并不处理日常事务，你知道的，例如，她通常不直接处理日常事务。比如，她通常不亲自领导，比如说，军队。但她可以召集他们参战。是的，但当国王御驾亲征时，她会被委任掌管国家。这就使她有资格被列为非洲亚马逊人。
he can actually leap in front of her to protect her. So she has incredible spiritual, you know, symbolic and political authority, but she doesn't actually handle the day to day, you know, so for example, she doesn't, usually she doesn't lead handle the day-to-day. So for example, she doesn't, usually she doesn't lead, let's say, for example, the army. But she can summon them to war. Yes, but when the king goes, she's put in charge of the state. So that qualifies her to rank as an African Amazon.
只有一个关于阿散蒂的问题。所以现在显然依然有阿散蒂国王。那么现在还有王太后吗？现在依然有王太后。对，对，对。而且她是否仍然像她的前任们一样受到同等的尊重和敬畏？是的，同样的尊重，同样的敬 reverence（敬意）。
Just one question about the Ashanti. So there is obviously still the king of the Ashanti. So is there still a queen mother? There is still a queen mother. Yeah, yeah, yeah. And is she still regarded in the same sort of, with the same respect and awe as her predecessors? Yeah, same respect, same reverence.
她不像以前那么抛头露面了。对。所以甚至确切地说，你知道的，虽然她掌握着那种权力，但是，你知道的，对于奥塞图图二世（Osei Tutu II）来说，是的，你知道的，她很大程度上是王权背后的掌权者。事实上，如果不是因为她的权威和她的首肯，他根本不可能成为国王，但通常情况下，我的意思是，现在更灵活了，
She's not as public a figure. Right. So even exactly, you know, with the kind of power she wields, but, you know, with Ossetia Tutu II, yeah, you know, she's very much the power behind the throne. In fact, he wouldn't have become, you know, king if not for, you know, her authority and her say so but usually i mean it's more flexible
通常就像我说的，以前是母亲，但现在也可以是姑母或姨母，这就像是一个年长的女性亲属，嗯——所以不管是甚至确切地说是他的母亲（很有可能），还是……嗯，不大确定。女王姑母，女王……确实如此，确实如此。听起来都很棒，但多米尼克在这一段开场时，对一个可能听起来稍微更让人闻之色变的人物进行了描述，这实际上是《弗莱什曼夫人》中唯一一段我可以宣读而不会导致播客被立即取消的内容。所以，卢克，拉纳瓦洛娜——马达加斯加的疯狂君主。所以她是19世纪的，对吧？这也是一个英国人和法国人都在施加影响力、扩张、向非洲挺进的时期，诸如此类，对吧？是的，她对此进行了反抗，那么她作为眼睛像蛇一样、
now usually like i say it was the mother but now it could be an answer it's like a senior female relative um so whether it's even exactly his mother probably is but um not too sure the queen aunt queen indeed indeed so they all sound great but dominic opened this segment with a description of of a perhaps possibly slightly more terrifying sounding figure that was actually the only bit of flashman's lady about her that i could read out without the podcast being cancelled immediately so luke ran avalona the mad monarch of madagascar so she's 19th century yeah and this is a period where the the british and the french are both kind of throwing their weight yeah expanding moving into africa all that kind of thing yeah and she takes a stand against this and is her reputation as a mad monarch with eyes like snakes
散发着纯粹邪恶的疯狂君主的声誉，这究竟是欧洲宣传的反映呢？因为她把他们赶走了，所以他们才跟她过不去？还是说这确实是事实？你知道吗？我认为这在很大程度上是一种反映。说实话，这并不是说拉纳瓦洛娜在自己的统治方式上就不残暴。我认为她是残暴的。但你拥有的许多资料基本上都来自19世纪的伦敦传教士，他们并不客观。这绝对带有某种视角。事实上，我们掌握的来自1850年代一位马达加斯加女性的少数资料之一，来自一位奥地利旅行家伊达· Pfeiffer（伊达·菲佛），她去了马达加斯加并见到了女王，她对女王的描述有点类似——我认为，说她在统治末期是个疯子未免有些夸张。但她绝对不是。对普通玛丽娜人（Marina）来说，生活在她的统治下绝对是一段严苛的时期，因为她极其崇尚传统。
that convey pure evil is this a reflection of european propaganda because i cross with her because they're being kicked out? Or is it actually true? Do you know what? I think it's largely a reflection. And to be honest, that's not to say that Rainer Walloner wasn't brutal in her own way. I think she was. But a lot of the sources you have are basically 19th century London missionaries who don't. There's definitely a certain perspective. And actually, one of the few sources we have from a Malagasy woman in the 1850s is an Austrian traveler, Ida Pfeiffer, who goes to Madagascar and she meets the queen and she describes her in sort of a similar mad at the end of her reign, I think, is an exaggeration. But she definitely wasn't. In terms of for the ordinary Marina, it was definitely a harsh reign to be under because she was uber traditional.
这就是其中的一个方面，因为她的丈夫拉德马（Radema）——她在丈夫去世后继承了王位——对欧洲和基督教的影响相当开放，而她则完全相反。因此她推行了许多这类制度，甚至在某些方面，对今天的我们来说绝对是传统玛丽娜社会中陈旧而残酷的制度，这对于19世纪的欧洲人来说确实相当令人震惊。所以我想这就是这种说法的来源。那么是什么呢，卢克？
That was the aspect is that she wanted to, because her husband, who she gains the throne from after he dies, Radema, was quite open to European and Christian influence, and she was the complete opposite. So she institutes a lot of these, and even in some respects, and definitely to us today, archaic and brutal institutions of traditional marina society, which especially to 19th century Europeans was really quite shocking. So I think that's where that comes from. So like what, Luke?
我想这也是所有听众都想知道的。是的。所以就是“坦吉纳”（tanguina），这就像是一种神裁法（trial by ordeal）。具体情况是，如果有人被指控犯了特定的罪行，通常这种事不常发生，一般都是非常严重的罪行，比如叛国罪。具体做法是，他们会被喂食一顿米饭和三块鸡皮，同时还要吃下坦吉纳植物种子的果仁。然后他们会被灌下大量的水，以便把刚吃下去的东西呕吐出来。如果他们把全部三块
That's what all the listeners want, I think. Yeah. So the tanguina, which is like a trial by ordeal. So what happens is if someone is accused of a particular crime, usually it doesn't happen often. It's usually very serious crimes like treason. What happens is that they're fed a meal of rice and three pieces of chicken skin, and then also the kernel of the seeds of a tanguina plant. And then they're fed lots of water in order to throw up what they've just eaten. And if they throw up all three of the
鸡皮都吐出来了，就被视为无辜。但如果没有全部吐出来，你知道，少于三块，就会被判定有罪并处死。这真是一场非常巴洛克式的审判，不是吗？是的，我知道，对吧？但情况是，拉德马为了讨好英国人，特别是让他的军队接受英国的武器和军事训练。他同意不对人类使用这种审判，而拉纳瓦洛娜转而将之用于狗。狗。
chicken skins, they're considered innocent. But if they don't throw up any, you know, less, less than three, they're considered guilty and put to death. That's a very Baroque trial, isn't it? Yeah, I know, right? But what happens is that Radema, again, wanting to cosy up to the British in particularly, actually takes British arms and agrees to have them trained militarily, his troops. He agrees not to use this trial on human beings, and Ranavalona instead on dogs. Dogs.
用在狗身上。所以他就像是在说，好吧，我们在狗身上做。希望这对你们来说没问题。而拉纳瓦洛娜又把这改回去了。所以这不是因为狗本身冒犯了什么。而是因为这只狗属于……可能属于那个人，或者是在代替那个人。是的。
On dogs. So he's like, all right, we'll do it on dogs. Hopefully that'll be fine for you. And Rana Valona takes it back. So this isn't because the dogs themselves have offended. It's because the dog belongs to the. Probably belongs to the person or is standing in for the person. Yeah.
所以你可能会被指控，汤姆，而你，比如说你有一只猫，叫伊迪丝。伊迪丝可以在这次审判中代替你。如果她把鸡皮吐出来了……
So you could be accused, Tom, and you could, you have a cat, for example, Edith. And Edith could stand in for you in this trial. And if she vomited up the chicken skins
她就会把它吐出来——我的意思是，我不想细说，但她是有前科的，现在没有任何一个排泄孔不是她在排泄的——哦，对了，太好了，这正在直播，太棒了。我不想细说，但我的意思是，如果她到处捕杀宠物——是的，难怪她在英国人眼里名声那么坏呢。——不，不，不，不。她又把它改回杀人了。这就是，这就是。对。我的意思是，事实是英国人可能对杀死狗比杀死人类更心烦意乱。但她在杀害基督徒。难道这才是关键所在吗？除了恢复这种做法之外，还有对基督徒的迫害。就像我说的，只因为她是个极端传统主义者。所以她，你知道的，她会召开大型集会，
she she would vomit it up I mean I don't want to go into details but she's got form there is no orifice she is not voiding at the moment oh right nice that's happening live fantastic I'm not going to go into the details but I mean so if she's going around killing pets yeah no wonder she has an evil reputation with the British well no no no, no, no. She takes it back to killing humans. That's what, that's what. Right. I mean, the thing is the British probably are more upset about dogs being killed than humans. But she's killing Christians. Isn't that the key thing? There's that in terms of taking back, but then it's a persecution of Christians. Like I say, just because she's, she's uber traditionalist. So she, you know, she holds these grand meetings
在会上她告诉基督徒要，你知道的，公开自己并进行谴责。而如果你——这就叫横竖都是死，如果他们主动站出来，有些人可能只是被罚一小笔款，但其他人则会被处死。当时有一位基督教先知，他提出了自己的苏格拉底式宗教，将基督教的某些方面与传统的玛丽娜宗教融合在一起，因为他曾是玛丽娜神明之一的守护祭司。他被送上审判并被处决。她甚至建立了一个间谍网用来根除基督教。所以，是的，我的意思是，她在30年代和40年代的统治期间发动了相当多的——18世纪30年代、40年代——针对基督徒的迫害，这显然让欧洲人不那么高兴。
where she tells Christians to, you know, to denounce themselves. And if you're sort of damned if you do, damned if you don't, if they do come forward, some of them maybe tell us to pay a small fine, but others executed. When there's a Christian prophet who's come up with his own Socratic religion, mixing aspects of Christianity with the traditional Marina religion, because he used to be a guardian priest of one of the marina gods. He's put on trial and he's executed. She has like a spy network and she used to root out Christianity. And yeah, so I mean, and she launches a fair few during her reign in the 30s and the 40s, 1830s, 1840s persecutions against Christians, which obviously doesn't sit well with Europeans.
但同时，王国里也有相当多的人在皈依。所以这有点像是一场恐怖统治。我读到的统计数据说，马达加斯加的人口在她的统治下减半了，从500万降至250万，这是真的吗？不，老实说，我认为这不是真的。我觉得这有点夸张。哦，这不是真的。我们这么说，但你知道，例如，当她进行清剿时，有些，你知道的，死亡的人不仅仅是因为，比如说，迫害。我的意思是，有时总数达到，你知道的，在她的统治期间，基督徒的死亡人数有几百甚至几千。
But then also, there were quite a few people who were, you know, converting in the kingdom as well. So it's a bit of a reign of terror. Is it true, the statistics I've read, that the population of Madagascar in her rule halved, went from 5 million to 2.5 million? No, I don't think that's true, honestly. I think it's a bit of an exaggeration. Oh, it's not true. We say that, but, you know, for example, when she's rooting out, there are some, you know, people who are dying from not just, for example, the persecutions. I mean, sometimes it comes to, you know, hundreds or even thousands of, you know, of Christians
但也包括，你知道的，那些因为过度劳累而死的人，你知道的。我的意思是，她在统治后期发起了一次水牛狩猎行动。而且，你知道的，拉德马不相信修建道路，因为他认为这会帮助敌军推进。而她遵照他的意愿，也没有修建像样的道路。但随后她在40年代组织了她所有的贵族及其家眷和她一起去进行水牛狩猎。她让手下的人在穿越的过程中顺便修路。但她也没有为物资供应做好规划，所以这些筑路工人就像苍蝇一样纷纷倒下，你知道的，被扔进
over the course of her reign. But also, you know, people who are dying, you know, for example, from overwork. I mean, she initiates, for example, like a buffalo hunt later on in her reign. And, you know, Radema didn't believe in building roads because he thought that they'd aid the advance of an enemy army. And she, in accordance with his wishes, also didn't build proper roads. But then she organizes for all of her nobles and their households to join her on this buffalo hunt in the 40s. And she gets some of her people to basically build the road as they're traversing. But she hadn't organized for the provisions as well so these constructors are just dropping like flies and you know being dumped into
乱葬岗里，然后更多的人被抓去顶替——所以这其中确实有夸张的成分。我认为就是来自这类事情。在《弗莱什曼》一书中有很多精彩的内容——汤姆，你读过《弗莱什曼》那本书吗？那是好几年前的事了——所以弗莱什曼来到了马达加斯加，他担任她的军事顾问，还有某种程度上的……以及面首（concubine），实际上应该说是种马（stud），“种马”这个词，对，种马。所以他经常处于恐惧之中，被她拖来拖去，他必须在 cue（暗示）下表现自己，吓得浑身发抖，但他还是照做了。但其中有一些场景，他刚和她办完事，然后她就会傲慢地把他推到一边，走到阳台上去。
into open graves and then more are being used to some exaggeration so i think that's it's from also those kinds of things there's tremendous seed in uh so in the flashman book so have you the flashman book tom years ago so flashman pitches up in madagascar he serves as her military advisor and sort of and concubine actually it's stud and stud stud is the word and stud so he's constantly being he's in terror of his life and he's sort of being dragged around by her and he has to sort of perform on cue and he's quaking in his boots but he does so but there are scenes where he will have just performed with her and then she will sort of imperiously brush to a side and go out onto the balcony.
而在楼下，关着许多瑟瑟发抖的疑似基督徒。她会指着其中的一群人说：“烧死。”然后她会指着另一群人说：“煮沸。”然后把这些酷刑经历了个遍。这真是非常亚马逊式的行为。这挺搞笑的。其实她确实经常这么做。
And down below, they've got lots of suspected Christians who are quaking themselves down below. She'll point at a group of them and she'll just say, burning. And then she'll point at another group and say, boiling. And go through all this. That's very Amazonian behaviour. That's quite funny. She did do it quite often, actually.
这些命令是由，你知道的，她的司法官员或类似的人宣读的。所以她实际上并不是亲自动手指出谁将被杀，但她会下达命令让他们去执行。不过我想她之所以能被称为亚马逊人，原因之一可能是，实际上，
These orders would be read by, you know, a member of her judiciary or something. So she wasn't actually doing it herself in terms of pointing out who would be killed, but she'd be giving orders for them to carry out. But I think one of the reasons maybe she ranks, you know, would rank as an Amazon is that actually, you know,
英国人和法国人对她和沿海地区发起了联合进攻。本质上，他们被击退了。最后以失败告终。随后她对英国人实施了禁运。她说她不会向毛里求斯和法国岛屿留尼汪（Grignion，原文如此）进口或出口牛。此后，这些岛屿上的商人实际上不得不向她支付罚款，当时相当于15,000美元。这就是她为她认为的侮辱所要求的赔偿。好吧。所以你可以理解为什么她名声会这么差了。
the British and the French launch a combined attack against her and against the coast. Essentially, they're pushed back. It ends up failing. And she then afterwards launches embargoes against the British. She says she's not going to import or export cows to the Mauritius and the French island of Grignion. And afterwards, the merchants on those islands actually end up paying her a fine, and at the time, $15,000. That's what she demands in exchange for what she considered an insult. Okay. So you can see why she'd have a bad rap.
完全正确。但显而易见，这一切背后其实还有一个完全相反的叙事，不是吗？那就是，你可以把整个故事讲述为：这是一个在巨大压力下进行英勇抵抗和领导的故事，有点像前半部分提到的恩津加。你当然可以这么说，因为确实存在，你知道的，相当大的压力。而且，你知道的，她对法国人的诉求之一，例如，是希望被承认马达加斯加女王。他们不肯给她。而且，你知道的，法国人和英国人正在该地区进行军事、经济、政治活动，由于她是一个极端传统主义者，你知道的，当她的军队击败了英法联军时，
Exactly. But obviously, there's a complete counter-narrative to all this, isn't there? Which would be, you could tell this whole story, and you could say this is a story of heroic resistance of leadership under tremendous, a little bit like Njinga in the first half. You can, you can for sure, because there is, you know, quite a lot of pressure. And, you know, one thing she wants from the French, for example, is to be recognised as the Queen of Madagascar. They won't give it to her. And, you know, the French and the British are engaging in activity in this area, military, economic, political, and because she's an uber traditionist, you know, when her forces defeat the British and French invasion, she's an uber tradition this you know when her forces defeat the british
入侵，她在他们中间被视为英雄。但同时，也有许多玛丽娜人遭受了痛苦，特别是那些皈依了基督教的人。所以，嗯，这些关于亚马逊人的故事如何根据你所处的位置和你的视角被解释和重新解释，这就把我们带回了我们这个播客开始时的话题——达荷美战士。那么你对他们有什么看法？我的意思是，这些确实存在。它们确实存在。现在你看，这很有趣，因为它们并不总是，例如，达荷美军队中的战斗部队。
french invasion she's seen as being a hero amongst them but then also there were a lot of marina who suffered as well and especially those who adopted christianity um so yeah the way in which these stories about amazons are interpreted and reinterpreted depending on where you're standing what your perspective is brings us back to the to the topic that we began this podcast with, the Dahomey warriors. So what's your take on them? I mean, these did exist. They did. Now, see, it's quite interesting because they weren't always, for instance, a fighting unit
在达荷美军队中，它们是后来才变成那样的，实际上它们最初是国王的贴身保镖，而且主要是礼仪性质的保镖。达荷美有一个习俗，我不太确定其起源，但达荷美有一个习俗，即不允许任何男性在国王的宫殿里过夜。所以如果他想组建保镖队伍，他必须由女性组成。这就是他说的。所以，是的，我的意思是，必须得这么做。最初，这些实际上是他的妃子。这也是名称“Ahosi”或“Ahosi”的来源。它的字面意思是国王的妻/妃，或者她们被称为“Mino”，即我们的母亲。所以她们最初实际上是从王宫里的女性群体中挑选出来的，
in the army, in the Dahomey army. They became that later on, and actually they start off as a bodyguard and a mostly ceremonial bodyguard for the king. There was a Dahomian custom, which I'm not sure the origins of, but there was a Dahomian custom that no man was allowed to sleep overnight at the king's palace. So if he wanted to have a bodyguard, he had to form them of women. That's what he said. So yeah, I mean, it has to be done. Initially, these were actually his wives. That's actually where the name Ahosi or Ahosi comes from. It literally means king's wives, or they're known as Mino, our mothers. So they're actually initially taken from the female group at the palace,
从王宫中挑选。所以在18世纪，她们在很大程度上充当了保镖的角色。事实上，在达荷美的传统中有这样的记载：例如，当发生权力斗争、不同派系为争夺王国统治权而战或者发生政变时，女性会保护她们的国王。当吉索（Gizo）掌权时，确实发生过这种情况——吉索是国王，也是女性国王。所以当吉索掌权时，他是通过政变掌权的。据说在前任王位所有者的女性在吉索掌权前非常勇敢地为保卫他而战。所以在18世纪，显然吉索是在19世纪掌权，但18世纪的
at the royal palace. So it's mainly in the 18th century, they act for the most part as a bodyguard. And actually there are reports in the traditions of Dahomey of when, for example, there were power struggles or when different factions were fighting against each other for rule of the kingdom, or there were coups, the women protected their king. It happened actually when Gizo, who is the king and the woman king. So when Gizo comes to power, he comes to power via a coup. And the women of the person from who takes the throne are said to have fought very bravely in his defense before Gizo comes to power. So in the 18th century, obviously Gizo comes by in the 19th century, but the 18th
达荷美亚马逊人非常类似于一种仪仗性质、部分具备军事功能的保镖队伍。事实上，正是吉索本人因将她们转变为军队中真正的战斗部队而受到赞誉，她们被用来与其他势力作战。她们被用来俘虏奴隶并将其出售给欧洲列强，是这样吗？我想，你知道的，如果对此进行剖析的话，显然她们会与非洲的其他群体发生战斗。例如，她们与约鲁巴人（Yoruba）作战，然后是大多数情况——这正是达荷美大多数被奴役之人的真实遭遇，特别是在18世纪阿加贾（Agarja）国王统治时期，大多数人，即战争俘虏，会在达荷美被用作农奴。然后剩下的部分就会
century, the Dahomian Amazons are very much like a ceremonial, partly militaristic bodyguard. And it's actually Gizo himself has credit for transforming them into a proper fighting unit in the army where they're used in wars against other powers. And they are used to capture slaves and to sell slaves to European powers. Is that right? I think, you know, the way that that would be, you know, broken down is that obviously they engage in battles with other groups in Africa. So for example, their fights against the Yoruba and then the majority, and this is what actually happened with the majority of the slave people in Dahomey, especially in the 18th century under the king, for instance, Agarja, is that most of the people, captives of war, would be used as serfs in Dahomey. And then what was left over would then
被交易给欧洲人，而他们的命运，你知道的，不得而知，也不是很确定。但她们实际上并没有被派去执行具体的奴役突袭行动，但她们经常俘虏人员，而这些人后来被当作奴隶卖掉。那么卢克，多米尼克在节目开始时用他那不朽的赞美之词对她们进行的描述——我把它读了出来，这绝不是为了贬低他作为非洲历史学家的地位——什么？——但所有关于斯巴达式教育、赤脚在荆棘上奔跑以及砍下人头之类的事情。是的。据我们所知，这是准确的吗？还是多米尼克在胡编乱造？
be traded to Europeans and their fates, you know, unknown, not really sure. But they weren't actually sent out on specific slave raiding expeditions, but they often captured people and more who then went on to be sold as slaves. And Luke, that description that Dominic gave us in his immortal praise that I read out at the beginning of the episode, and not in any way to impugn his status as a historian of Africa. What? But all that kind of stuff about the Spartan upbringing, kind of running barefoot on thorns and chopping off heads and things. Yeah. Is this accurate as far as we know, or is Dominic making it up?
我可不是胡编乱造的。这来自旅行者的故事，汤姆。法国军官什么的。所以，我的意思是，好吧。好吧，法国军官，对，作为训练制度的一部分。我的意思是，她们是否真的那么血腥还有待商榷，但显然存在相当严厉的训练制度，因为，你知道的，达荷美的女性和达荷美军队中的女性士兵部队，
I'm not making it up. It's from the traveller's stories, Tom. French officers and whatnot. So, I mean, okay. Okay. French officers, yeah, as part of the training regime. I mean, whether they were as bloody is obviously to be debated, but there was obviously quite a harsh training regime because, you know, the women, you know, the Dahomian women and the unit of female
根据18世纪和19世纪许多欧洲旅行者的记载，被认为比军队中的男性表现得好得多，更勇敢，也更擅长使用滑膛枪。事实上，有很多传统记载，例如，当达荷美人与约鲁巴人的城镇作战时，当男性被打退时，实际上是女性冲进去并确保了最终赢得战斗。所以她们确实经历了一个严格的过程。而且她们的人数也很少。我的意思是，她们最初的人数最多只有800人。在吉索统治下，她们得到了制度化和扩展，人数达到了大约3000人。她们的构成、编组以及在战场上的运作方式与达荷美主力军队（或至少是
soldiers in the Dahomian army are reckoned by a lot of the accounts of 18th and 19th century European travelers to be a lot better fighters than, you know, the men of the army as well, better, you know, braver and better at using muskets. And actually there are a lot of traditions, for example, when, you know, the Dahomans are fighting against, you know, towns of the Yoruba, for instance, that when the men are pushed back, it's actually the women who go in and secure, you know, who help them win the battle at the end. So they definitely had come through a rigorous process. There's also very few of them. I mean, they start off numbering the maximum 800. And on the Gizo, well, they're sort of institutionalized and expanded. They go to about 3000. And their makeup, the way they're constituted and the way they operate in the field is similar to how the main Dahomian army, or at least the
达荷美男性军队）的运作方式相似。所以她们得到了充分且非常有效的利用。她们不是什么辅助部队之类的。她们是达荷美军队中非常重要的一支部队。我想我有两点要说。第一点是，比如说，那个描述杀害被俘青年女性的法国军官让·拜奥（Jean Bayol），他砍下了男子的头。L'Amesca。我的意思是，完全有可能，当然，
male Dahomian army also operates. So they're utilized very much and very effectively. They're not like a support unit or anything like that. They are very much an important unit of the Dahomian army. I suppose there's two things I would say. One is that, so for example, that French officer, Jean Bayol, who is describing the woman who kills a captured young man, she cuts his head off. L'Amesca. I mean, it's perfectly possible, of course,
这在布赖顿（Brighton）是为了给法国人留下深刻印象而摆拍出来的。你知道的，这不一定是常态，但这是一场大型表演。回到你前半部分所说的话，人们希望被认为令人畏惧、令人生畏以及诸如此类的一切。希望被认为令人畏惧，这绝对是真实的。我的意思是，本质上是因为天气——
that is being staged in Brighton to impress the French. You know, that it's not necessarily the norm, but this is a big demonstration. Going back to what you said in the first half, people want to be thought of as fearsome and formidable and all the rest of it. Want to be thought of as fearsome, very true. I mean, essentially it's because of the weather.
我不知道，可能吧，我不知道关于喝血的事，但达荷美人的确会砍下人头，因为实际上，人头，那是你用来交给国王并按人头领赏的东西之一。但同样，正如欧洲人的报告中显然提到人头在达荷美国王宫殿旁腐烂的情况……
I don't know, possibly, I don't know about the drinking of the blood, but I mean the Dahomians definitely did decapitate, you know, because actually the heads, that was actually one of the things that you used to take to the king and you'd be paid per head that you gave to the king. But then again, as European reports apparently reports of heads, you know, rotting like
你知道的，但我认为实际上存在一种制度，即因为交出人头或活着的俘虏（理想情况下），但你知道，被砍下的人头而获得国王的报酬，所以你可以得到报酬。另一个我想说的是，我们永远无法
you know, by the palaces of the Dahomian kings. But I think actually there was a system of, you know, getting paid for giving you know, heads or life captives ideally, but you know, decapitated heads to the king and you get paid for it so well that was the other thing i was going to say though is that we can't ever
摆脱这样一个事实：这个故事的很大一部分，甚至——如果你说得刻薄一点的话——我们之所以把这个做成播客，其实也反映了一种欧洲人某种病态的迷恋，是的。而且某种程度上，甚至像《女王》这样电影的成功，也带有某种民间记忆的色彩——哦，既迷人、性感，又极其暴力。是的。你不这么认为吗？你觉得这公平吗，卢克？
quite get away from the fact that so much of this story and indeed you could i mean if you were being harsh you would say even the fact that we're doing this as a podcast is a reflection of a sort of prurient european fascination yes yeah and some extent, even the success of a film like The Woman King, there's a slight folk memory of this sort of, oh, glamorous, sexy, but also incredibly violent. Yeah. Do you not think that? Do you think that's fair, Luke?
我想是的。但我也认为这也是时代的一种反映，你知道的。我的意思是，我是世界历史的超级粉丝。每当我阅读，你知道的，甚至关于十字军东征的历史，或者如果你在阅读，你知道的，关于欧洲战争、二战的历史，我的意思是，你就会发现，你知道的，这只是历史的一个方面，要么是人们着迷的方面，要么有时只是时代的标志。我的意思是，你知道的，恩津加，举个例子，很大程度上是环境的受害者，你知道的，她并不是刻意去从事她所做的事情，达荷美人的女王也不是刻意设定的。但这也是真的，事实上也是如此。存在着一种迷恋。但同时，这也是一个方面，就像不同的欧洲列强，你知道的，在中国、印度或任何地方，都有不同的势力在互相征战一样。只是在非洲也发生了类似的事情，尤其是在这些残酷的时期。但你不认为她们是女性这一点让它变得更……
I think so. But I think also sometimes a reflection of the times, you know. I mean, I'm a big fan of world history. Whenever I read, you know, the history even of the Crusades or if you're reading about, you know, the wars in Europe, World War II, I mean, you just see that, you know, this is just an aspect of, you know, history, either that people are fascinated by, or sometimes just the sign of, you know, a sign of the times then. I mean, you know, Njinga, for example, was, you know, was to a large extent a victim of circumstance, you know, she didn't set out to engage in what
哦，特指女性吗？是的。我认为从欧洲人的角度来看，是的。我认为从非洲人的角度来看，就像我们刚才说的，这并不那么不寻常，但它绝对是某种……而且我不认为这本身有什么对或错，
she did, the Dahomians didn't set her. But it's true, actually, as well. There's a kind of fascination. But also, you know, it was an aspect of, in the same way that, you know, different European powers, you know, in China, India, wherever, you had different groups fighting against each other. It's just that you had the, you know, similar thing happening in Africa, especially in, you know, in these brutal periods. But you don't think the fact that they're women makes it more…
这只是文化发展的方式。对于为什么非洲会有女性，为什么非洲的女性人物在如此多的不同方面变得重要，人们提出了多种理论。这与环境有关，但也与宗教和文化有关。我的意思是，你知道的，有如此多、如此多的不同解释，但在非洲的语境中，这并不被视为不寻常，但绝对在西方语境中，让女性以这种方式战斗，所以，你知道的，
Oh, women specifically? Yeah. I think from the European perspective, yes. I think from an African perspective, like we were saying earlier on, it's not that unusual, but it's definitely something that's just not... And I don't think there's anything right or wrong
冲在最前线，而且显然维多利亚时代关于女性被高高捧在基座上、不能做这个、必须受到呵护的理想。这带来了更多的文化分量。所以我想你是对的。我想确实如此，但这其实很简单，而且这是随意的，仅仅是因为非洲某些社会的发展方式以及欧洲某些社会的发展方式不同。好吧，卢克，多么精彩的环球纵论啊。我真的觉得你不应该再参加任何播客了，你应该全身心投入到完成你的书——《祖国：非洲历史的50万年》（Motherland: 500,000 Years of African History）中去。我已经迫不及待想读它了。谢谢你。而且显然，当我说道“不要再参加任何播客”时，我是
about this per se. It's just the way that the cultures have developed. There are multiple theories put for why Africa does have female, female figures in Africa become important in so many different aspects. And it's related to environment, but also religion and culture. I mean know important in so many different aspects and it's you know related to environment but also religion and culture i mean you know so many so many different explanations but you know in an african context not seen as unusual but definitely in a in a western context having you know women you know fighting in that in that regard so you know
就其本身而言，这只是文化发展的方式。关于为什么非洲会有女性形象在许多不同方面变得如此重要，有多种理论提出。这与环境有关，但也与宗教和文化有关。我的意思是，在许多不同的方面都很重要，你知道，这与环境有关，但也与宗教和文化有关，我的意思是，你知道，有那么多不同的解释，但在非洲语境下并不被视为不寻常，但在西方语境下，有女性在那方面战斗，所以你知道
up in the front line and and also obviously the victorian ideals about women being held up on the pedestal and they can't do this and they have to be let up. There's a lot more cultural weight for them. So I think you're right. I think it is, but I think that's just simply because, and it's arbitrary, it's just simply because of the way certain societies in Africa developed and simply the way certain societies in Europe are developed. Well, Luke, what a fascinating tour d'horizon. And I really think you shouldn't come on any more podcasts and you should just devote yourself to finishing your book motherland 500 000 years of african history i cannot wait to read it thank you and obviously when i say don't come on any more podcasts i'm
冲在最前线，而且很显然，维多利亚时代关于女性被高高捧在神坛上、她们不能这样做而必须被照顾的理念。她们承受着更多文化分量。所以我认为你是对的。我认为确实如此，但我觉得这很简单是因为（而且这很随意），仅仅是因为非洲某些社会的发展方式，以及欧洲某些社会的发展方式。好吧，卢克，多么引人入胜的宏观概述啊。我真的认为你不应该再参加任何播客了，而应该全身心投入到完成你的书《祖国：非洲历史的50万年》中，我已经迫不及待想读它了。谢谢你，显然我说“别再上任何播客了”是指
excluding us because it would be wonderful to have you back and talk other aspects of african history thank you so much so much for that thank you everyone for listening and we'll be back very soon with more history more history dope as reagan might put it bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye thanks for listening to the rest is history for bonus episodes early access ad-free listening and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
不算我们，因为很高兴能请你回来聊聊非洲历史的其他方面。非常感谢，太感谢了。谢谢大家的收听，我们很快就会带回更多历史，正如里根所说的那样精彩的历史。再见，再见，再见。感谢收听《The Rest is History》，想要获取额外节目、抢先收听、无广告体验以及访问我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad-free listening bonus episodes and early access to There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论和一点八卦猛料。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想要无广告收听、额外节目和抢先体验... 本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。